okay hello everyone welcome to part two
of my resident evil 4 in vr gameplay uh
i made a couple of changes based on the
comments that you guys gave me for the
first one this is my first time
recording vr like this so
trying to keep evolving it i've changed
the turning to smooth
uh it might make me too sick though so
we'll see i might have to change it back
to the snap turn because i do get vr
sickness um
i also got rid of my chair i'm now
sitting on a stool which i think is
gonna work a little bit better so let's
do it uh please keep giving me feedback
so i can fine-tune this but i'm actually
super excited uh because i'm now further
away from my desk and i have a little
bit more space around me so some things
should be slightly easier um let's do it
okay so we had just
saved
and i know that there's somebody over
there
and that i want to go shoot this let's
just reload anyway i realized that i was
not reloading very much
[Music]
what was that
i can't reach it it can't reach it what
is it oh god
uh well that's lost forever
oh oh a
it sure does but what about the thing i
dropped in there all right never mind
um
i did also wanna
yeah i'm not reloading because it feels
like when you have a clip
like if it's eight of
uh
69 right now
then you do that
it actually doesn't it just feels like
when you physically have a clip that
you'd be throwing bullets away which
you're not
but it really really feels that way
okay
hello my friends how's everybody doing
today you guys having a having a good
time
hi buddy
hello
how are you
very noisy cows everybody's chill though
right i'm scared because
the ones in re8 really
kicked the [ __ ] out of me i also
realized i wasn't talking this properly
i just keep hitting the trigger twice
but you can actually
anyway
just put the gun down and grab the titty
knife just in case
hello dog
is this the dog i rescued earlier
[Music]
oh i got very worried it was going to
attack me
got my meat's grabbing eggs
yeah the part where i rescued the dog um
i cut out because it was you guys
probably did see it funny hey i'm just
trying to grab that egg my friend that's
a fence
that's a fence
um
that was the one part where the the
capture unsynced itself so
all right
anything in here
nothing here except a stinking pulled
manure that does not look like manure
these cows have diarrhea
and somebody is not taking care of their
property also
it's just no grass just
the state of this paddock how are they
even alive who is feeding you and what
oh god
oh my god
i somehow completely missed the giant
pile of [ __ ] dead bodies
jesus christ
that is
much scarier in vr
that one at the back there
this guy
wow
i can't believe this they're all dead
bodies they're sure
what's that what's that what's up what's
up
chicken
just chicken
um i kind of want to see if i can be
nice to the dog
bunny are you okay
hi
[Music]
i'm gonna stop bugging him but i want
him to know that he is loved
teddy knife let's go
teddy nade nope
there is another [ __ ] over there
somewhere right let's just go shoot him
just go shoot him right in his stupid
face
[Applause]
also everybody kept telling me to kick
what does it jump up an a
i'm just not sure how to do it
there's some way that i'm able to kick
you but i don't know what it is
when it's just one of them oh
she spoke too soon
it's possible that i'm like it's just
like it is showing up on the gameplay
capture but i can't see it or something
stop running
all right
[Music]
what am i gonna do with all these eggs
is the juke here
oh
um excuse me microphone
about the blue medallions
[Music]
15 blue medallions seven in the farm
eight in the cemetery
for those of you who destroy ten or more
you'll be rewarded the rest is illegible
all right we'll take it
they probably should have made that
gameplay huh
all right
titty knife
nope wrong kidding
happens to the best of us
phew
[Music]
i haven't seen anymore just yet
anybody in here
anybody
oh
oh god oh [ __ ]
[Music]
he actually shook me a bit okay
anything
doesn't look like it
you know
drop knife grab egg
great exchange
barrels
looks like they can be broken okay it's
knife time
now i have more room look at me go
excuse me
oh my god
mucho mucho mucho de nero
[Music]
microphone
maybe if i do one of these in the future
i'll get one of the
the mod mics but i didn't want to
have to wait on something to arrive for
the purposes of this gameplay
any more blue medallions anywhere
no
yet
chicken
watch yourself
we're not doing that right
now we gotta pull it back
i don't know how to use guns
four huh yeah i need a lot more than i
currently have
i'll tell you that much
you think you'd aim at that
knock down
what
leon
why did we do that
i
feel like i could have used that
oh
good day sir
okay
was it empty
devastating
that seems to be
most everything
very close to the desk here we're very
close
[Music]
come on
come on
nice
okay
i feel like this door is not going to
open but let's give it a shot no nothing
okay
sometimes you just got to throw your gun
away you know what i'm saying
and then we're going to jump down here i
think
is there anything here to check out
nada
hmm
maybe from the other side
[Music]
i wonder if i can break this probably
not right
is there an opening to it somewhere else
come on leon you just gotta get good
dude
all right well
there probably is some way to deal with
that but uh i don't know what it is yet
and i assume that i will backtrack
because it's resident evil
don't really look like there's much in
there anyway
you all need to chill
so
i think that's all good
house of confinement well i hate that
for me
okay
jaisa
oh i didn't expect that to work
physics [ __ ] microphone
i've seen this signpost before
okay
oh my god
oh running
oh gosh
no that was a mechanic
okay
well
are they gonna do it every time or what
like what is
wish you [ __ ] beef
get
oh my god a sniper rifle's gonna be so
much fun
all right well
he dropped something but it's all the
way up there surely i'll get up there
surely surely surely
the glowy things are a lot easier to
spot
well
yep i see that
uh okay harder to shoot at though and i
probably should really at this point
just get rid of that calorie count
but i do mostly use vr for fitness
hey
hey hey
hey
i'm gonna be teddy knife here [ __ ]
zoo badass
set up
i have no quarrel with your client
you about to get teddy knifed my friends
get out of here get out of here leon we
don't have time
ain't got time for no bats
sup
[ __ ] punk
okay they're really just just waiting
for me here huh
well
why are you waiting so patiently
that's strange
typically literally everything they do
is ominous but
[ __ ]
this feels like
extra ominous
am i supposed to stealth
is that the suggestion
where are you going
i don't think i can crouch
hey
is creepy
um
i don't respect your use of exploities
that's not a dynamite dude is this
nathan drink look at him
oh i exploded it with a trap
that's gotta hurt um
oh god
who taught you how to throw
oh his head exploded about time though
how many headshots did that dude take
no no no no no no you can't be doing all
that
yeah dead
level three
i feel like the guns
they could have probably made them say
whatever
[ __ ] off no
it's a good army's got on him
i just need to get a shot on you
i can't
also those might be traps i'm seeing in
the grass there they are
it's fine
is that me walking
[ __ ] guy
[ __ ] back
are there two of you in there
nice
i'm gonna have to get in there somehow
because there's somebody over there
right
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's a waste of ammo
it's not a good idea
too thirsty i'm toy thirsty
gotta play a little bit slower than that
one at a time
okay where's the door so i can get in to
your house so i can kill you
[Music]
oh god
just one dude just appearing in vr is
terrifying because it feels like they're
in your personal space
kick trump oh my god leon
that's what everybody was talking about
when they were talking about the kick
hang on hang on let me knife him
the [ __ ]
today knife did not work because it was
a noble strategy but uh
it did not pay off
sorry nathan drake
today is not your day
i haven't even used the shotgun yet
how is my inventory looking i should
check oh something about that movement
made me feel a bit sick um where are we
going weapons and recovery
oh what a mess what a mess um
this is just no who needs this many eggs
for any reason at all
oh my god yep that one definitely made
me sick something about whatever i just
did there
oh boy
it's weird vr motion sickness to me is
like
i just get really hot all of a sudden i
really can't do much about that right
now
i just want to move you there i can't
you tell me i can't fine
um
this
is fine it's not my finest work
but it'll do
okay
out we go
so it wasn't me making that noise after
all it's some [ __ ] in this house
god
all right where are you going
damn it
i feel like
i feel like i want to shoot that
yes
probably a bunch of them that i should
be shooting
um
hello whoever is making this noise
it's been a long time since i saved
i didn't think that would work
just for safety you know
i think i have to grab the handle
hello
okay
okay bye
oh god
we should be safe for a little bit right
[Music]
i see something shiny
maybe not
okay
safe
um i would like to know if i can
i can that's [ __ ] cool
ah that rules uh where am i right now
confinement
gone
fine
meant
sometimes you just hit yourself in the
face
hell yeah that's so rad
okay how are we doing
all right
starters we're just gonna
do that
what is this [ __ ] noise man
and why
oh god
i hate that
nano
[ __ ]
all right
[Music]
push it it's so weird that every now and
then it's like my body comes out of me
like an astral prediction
to like do something on my behalf
oh what the [ __ ] dude
uh what the [ __ ]
um
okay
okay just to dual wield
there's a chance this is her right
okay
that is not a woman
but i'll take it
oh this guy little rough don't you think
i remember this guy okay
oh
you're not like them
no
you
no i'm ezio ortore
just based on the okay the best you know
i have only one very important question
okay go ahead
you gotta smoke
got gum
[ __ ]
perfect
a largeman
the big cheese what
oh no leon your roundhouse kick has
failed you
it was never gonna work forever dude
it's never gonna work forever
oh okay
we finished the chapter it was still
convinced that was gonna be a boss fight
immediately and it wasn't hit ratio 88
we can take
i wish it would tell me the amount of
collectibles i missed but that's fine
um
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay listen listen we're just gonna go
right here
and we're gonna go
chapter
this is so much fun to me
too
dark
yeah it looks like it says chapter two
street
okay feeble humans
let us give you our power
oh is this like scarecrow situation
that's not great
i don't love that for us
you will become unable to resist this
intoxicating power
hey
hey wake up
indeed
crawl out of one hole and into another
you want to tell me what's going on here
americano see
now what brings a bloke like you to this
part of the world oh hey easy
whoever you are
name's leon came here looking for this
girl
she's 12.
what is clearly to be a cop or something
nah you don't look the type
maybe
who told you psychic powers
oh the church was locked right is that
this house is that the house that we are
in right now who might you be
that one actually hurt i used to be a
cop in madrid
but now i'm just a good for nothing guy
who happens to be quite the ladies man
show
why'd you quit
policy uh you put your life on the line
nobody really appreciates you enough for
it oh shiny thing
here you left ammo when you're cracked
up to be anymore
used to be a cop myself
only for a day though
i thought i was bad
somehow i managed to get myself involved
with the incident in raccoon city on my
first day in the force
that is the incident with the viral
outbreak right
indeed i think i might stand a sample of
the virus in a lab at the department
i love how i can steal wheeled stuff
with leon's hands
oh
even though he's tied up
they didn't take anything off him
oh my god he's fabulous leon kennedy
everybody
you trying to tell me this this man
isn't
i don't know perfect
what a
what a man
god damn
i love a man who can do gymnastics
personally it's leon sorry i couldn't
get in touch sooner but i was a bit
tired nice you're okay right i'm fine
there was a male civilian held captive
according to him ashley's in a church
somewhere what happened to him he
managed to escape
do you have a fix on the location of
that church no
but apparently there's a secret passage
in the village it leads there i'm
heading back to the village
all right what happened to the duty we
just [ __ ] knocked on the ground
where the [ __ ] did he just go
what
what
shouldn't he be in here
did he leon did he get up while you're
on the phone you stupid piece of [ __ ]
ah
okay
um excuse me
gracie
okay
i still think i want to have the shot
going out for the close quarters and
just you know just in case
over here it's dragging i'll tell you
ah i've got everybody give me [ __ ]
shopkeeper
and if i do don't mind
if i do all right these ones are real
close sorry about that nope come on nope
nope nope nope
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean we can
just do that that's fine
i'm all right with it
[Music]
thank you
he's probably fine we can make a titty
knife and a gun work keep the knife
open the door
[Music]
seems okay
[Music]
what's this
nothing
the answer is that it is nothing
hey sexy cape man liam we don't have a
gun at right now what about continuity
got something that might interest you
oh my god a selection of good things on
sales
thank you
don't know if you noticed stranger but i
but did just see the blue medallions
hanging around in the village i didn't i
noticed them at the farm but i didn't
notice them
in the
village slash
oh wait aren't they in the cemetery have
i been to the cemetery i don't remember
come back after you've shot 10 or more
of them i've got a specialized gun i
want you to try out i would love to do i
would love to
um do you have anything yourself what
are you selling i don't know do you eat
eggs
probably not
oh
let's get up on me like that what are
you buying i'm gonna get rid of all of
this it's not worth it bye what are you
buying
a treasure map of the village hmm
handgun shotgun rifle bro
you tell me i can afford a rifle oh my
god i can
oh
oh
oh no
oh [ __ ] i don't know what i want to buy
[ __ ]
i can't get this for some reason oh it's
out of stock so it's going to come later
i mean i do have both of those though
right treasure map
no
that's [ __ ] cool
is that old stranger i'm gonna do it
do i have room for it
um
we can make room i think
what get
okay
you love to see it all right i feel
pretty good about that bye
thank you
no worries bro i have mucho mucho mucho
dinero
um
i wasn't gonna go with the rifle i will
but i just didn't want to do it yet
that is gonna be really fun when you add
the scope
rocket launcher
baby
thanks man oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you really are
very close can i touch him
yeah
i got your nose i got your nose
that i'm making myself uncomfortable so
um
all right
am gonna save here because i do have
trouble playing this for long periods of
time
[Music]
without getting
motion sick and i am feeling it a little
bit right now i'm actually gonna we're
gonna go down one for that one
so maybe yeah maybe half an hour i
usually try to play games for an hour
when i do let's plays but uh
it's
a bit tougher and beyond um
god
[Music]
did i just cancel it i might have but
whatever
is it that it is there all right
we uh
[Music]
whatever
my favorite um all right i'm gonna leave
this here thank you all for watching
i
need a drink of water so that's where
we're at